die deutschen Waffen sind sehr präzise
alles Hightech hier von der
Zielerfassung bis zur Handhabung das ist
es was wir brauchen Waffen können töten
aber töten tun ja nicht die Waffen
sondern die Menschen und ein Mensch kann
auch ohne Waffen töten deutsche Waffen
sind Exportschlager für sogenannte
Kleinwaffen erteilte die Bundesregierung
doppelt so viele Genehmigungen wie im
Jahr zuvor diese Ausschnitt ist 10 Jahre
alt und trotzdem super aktuell denn nie
wurden mehr deutsche Waffen ins Ausland
exportiert als in den vergangenen beiden
Jahren dabei hatte die Ampel eigentlich
geplant rüstungsexportes stärker zu
beschränken doch das war vor dem Krieg
gegen die Ukraine das
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium hat die
Rüstungsexporte des vergangenen Jahres
bekannt gegeben insgesamt genehmigte das
Ministerium Exporte im Wert von 8,36
Milliarden Euro Lieferungen an die
Ukraine 100 Milliarden Euro extra für
die Bundeswehr all das wirkt gerade wie
ein Konjunkturprogramm für die deutsche
Rüstungsindustrie
aber über wen reden wir hier eigentlich
das klären wir in dieser Folge Kontext
ich bin Lana grosse und neu hier
herzlich willkommen wir brauchen eine
laufende Produktion von wichtigen Waffen
Geräten und Munitionen gerade erst
forderte Scholz eine Stärkung der
deutschen Industrie um die Ukraine
effizienter unterstützen zu können doch
schon jetzt zählt Deutschland zu den
größten waffenexporteuren weltweit Platz
Nummer 5 nach den USA Russland
Frankreich und China deutsche
Rüstungskonzerne haben Hochkonjunktur so
bitter das auch klingen mag trotzdem ist
der Anteil der Rüstungsindustrie an der
gesamtwirtschaftsleistung relativ klein
schauen wir dazu mal auf den größten
Industriezweig in Deutschland die
Automobilbranche diese exportierte 2021
Waren im Wert von mehr als 200
Milliarden Euro der Wert exportierter
Rüstungsgüter lag im selben Jahr bei
9,35 Milliarden nach der angekündigten
panzerfertigung auf ukrainischem Boden
stand rein Metall heute als neues
Mitglied im Deutschen Index im
Rampenlicht mit 6,4 Milliarden Euro
Umsatz im vergangenen Jahr ist rein
Metall der größte deutsche
Waffenproduzent und bekannt für seine
Panzer der Schützenpanzer Marder präzise
modern und Feuerstab ob Marder Puma DAX
Biber oder Leguan viele Großgeräte der
Bundeswehr tragen Tiernamen der
Rüstungskonzern Rheinmetall wird in
Deutschland eine umfangreiche neue
munitionsfertigung aufbauen mit den Ziel
die Bundeswehr unabhängig versorgen zu
können die Anlagen sollen im Juni die
Produktion aufnehmen und auch Munition
für die deutschen Gepard Panzer in der
Ukraine produzieren der Radpanzer Boxer
hergestellt von kmw und Rheinmetall auch
die Panzer Gebhard und Puma stellt
reinmetall in Kooperation mit Krauss mal
verweg man her für den Panzer Leopard
die vor drei Metall KMW außerdem Teile
gefertigt werden Leopard Panzer von
einem der wichtigsten Rüstungskonzerne
Deutschlands Kraus Wegmann in den
Fertigungshallen dürfen wir die
Produktion des radpanzers Boxer drehen
unter strengen Sicherheitsauflagen als
führender deutscher Anbieter für
gepanzerte Rad und Kettenfahrzeuge macht
doch die Firma KMW Milliardenumsätze mit
Rüstungsgütern die Zusammenarbeit mit
der Bundeswehr ist eng 2012 Bad KMW dort
um Hilfe bei der militärischen Erprobung
neuer Panzer wie stark die
Verflechtungen zwischen Politik
Bundeswehr und KMW sind wird auch durch
ein Dokument deutlich dass uns vorliegt
der Leopard Panzer wurde bereits in der
Wüste Saudi-Arabiens getestet mit
massiver Unterstützung der Bundeswehr
eine zweifelhafte Kooperation denn das
privatwirtschaftliche Unternehmen kamen
wie nutzte so indirekt öffentliche
Gelder zum Testen neuer Produkte und
noch gravierender die Lieferung
deutscher Panzer nach Saudi-Arabien war
damals politisch ziemlich umstritten den
Beitrag dazu findet ihr in voller Länge
in der ZDF Mediathek weltweit liegt der
größte deutsche Rüstungskonzern
Rheinmetall übrigens auf Platz 31 die
größten 3 kommen aus den USA
auf Platz 1 ist Lockheed Marten
Produzent der F35 Kampfjets von denen
Deutschland jetzt übrigens 35 für die
Bundeswehr bestellt hat Umsatz
60,3 Milliarden US-Dollar und 7 Mal so
viel wie der Wert aller deutschen
Rüstungsexporte zusammen auf Platz 69
liegt die deutsche Firma hensold die
Besonderheit hier seit 2020 gehört mehr
als ein Viertel des Unternehmens dem
deutschen Staat ganz besonders stolz
sind wir über die strategische
Beteiligung der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland an unserem Unternehmen den
Kauf der hensold-aktien begründete die
Regierung mit sicherheitspolitischen
Aspekten als das Unternehmen an die
Börse ging wollte der Bund durch den
Erwerb von 25,1% der Aktien also einer
sogenannten sperminorität Einfluss aus
dem Ausland verhindern denn die von
hänselt entwickelte Sensorik gehört zu
den Schlüsseltechnologien der Bundeswehr
der letzte deutsche Rüstungskonzern den
wir uns jetzt anschauen ist weltweit
zwar nicht unter den Top 100
aber mit deutlichen Umsatzsteigerungen
rechnen denn er ist ein wichtiger
Ausstatter der Bundeswehr und ein
bekannter Name und kochwaffen werden
unter anderem von der deutschen Polizei
und von NATO-Truppen genutzt das G36
Sturmgewehr ist die Standardwaffe der
Bundeswehr das G36 kennen wir alle
spätestens seit dem Skandal um
angebliche Mängel bei der
Treffsicherheit und tauchte immer wieder
in kriegs- und Krisengebieten auf im
libyschen Bürgerkrieg 2011 präsentieren
sowohl Gaddafis Sohn als auch Rebellen
das G36 Gewehr in diesem Fall aus dem
Jahr 2011 Versicherten Hersteller und
Bundesrepublik die Waffen nicht nach
Libyen geliefert zu haben Heckler und
Koch erklärte damals die Waffen würden
aus einer Lieferung nach Ägypten stammen
und da liegt ein Problem obwohl
bestimmungsländer versichern müssen die
Waffen nicht weiterzugeben wird der
endverbleib nur unzureichend
kontrolliert Kleinwaffen sind im Prinzip
dass das gefährlichste was sie haben
können wenn es um die Tödlichkeit geht
also sterben mehr Leute mit mit kleinen
als ich irgendeine andere Waffe dazu
kommt auch dass die quasi aus
exportkontrollsicht unheimlich schwierig
zu kontrollieren sind also das ist eines
der Güter dass sie ich sag mal quasi in
dem Koffer mit transportieren können
2015 brachte die Bundesregierung dann
ein Pilotprojekt an den Start und prüft
seitdem den Verbleib von kleinen Waffen
durch sogenannte postshipment-kontrollen
all das hilft aber nicht bei
illegalen Waffenlieferungen die
Polizisten nutzten auch das Sturmgewehr
G36 des deutschen Waffenherstellers
Heckler und Koch diese Waffen hätten nie
in Guerrero sein dürfen Heckler und Koch
erst schlicht sich die
endverbleibserklärung und exportierte
Waffen in explizit nicht
belieferungsfähige mexikanische
Bundesstaaten Jahre später wurde der
Waffenhersteller dafür unter anderem zu
3 Millionen Euro Strafe verurteilt alle
14 Minuten stirbt ein Mensch durch
deutsche Waffen das hat das Kinderhaus
um 2018 errechnet
Millionen von Menschen die verstümmelt
sind verkr ein bisschen traumatisiert
sind durch den Einsatz dieser Waffen und
es sind nicht nur deutsche Kleinwaffen
durch die Menschen in kriegs- und
Krisengebieten getötet werden besonders
begehrt deutsche Produkte Panzer
Sturmgewehre sie sind weltweit im
Einsatz legal aber auch illegal so kam
es dass die Giftgas Aufrüstung des Irak
erst der Anfang war seit Mitte der 80er
Jahre lieferten deutsche Firmen
Basistechnologie für
Massenvernichtungswaffen in den Irak und
schließlich auch die dazu nötigen
Trägersysteme Granaten Kanonen und
Raketen die Maschinen und
rüstungsbaufirma Fritz Werner im
hessischen Geisenheim aber Ausfuhr
Genehmigung für Munitionsfabriken im
Wert von über 120 Millionen Marken
Ausfuhren in den Iran und dies während
des laufenden Iran Irakkrieges so der
Spiegel in seiner neuesten Ausgabe
Kopfen und Muslime geraten aneinander
die Armee sitzt Panzerwagen eingebaut
seit den 80ern unter deutsch auch
Nachschub kommt aus Deutschland haben
Sie schon mal ein schlechtes Gewissen
gehabt nein
mangelnde endverbleibskontrolle
Ausnahmeregelungen unzureichende
Transparenz oder schlichtweg betrug all
diese Beispiele zeigen dass deutsche
Waffen immer wieder in Krisengebieten
eingesetzt werden und ein kriegen
beteiligt sind und das obwohl die
Branche besonderen Regularien unterliegt
klar ist Rüstungsgüter können aus
Deutschland nicht einfach so exportiert
werden im Grundgesetz steht zur
Kriegsführung bestimmte Waffen dürfen
nur mit Genehmigung der Bundesregierung
hergestellt befördert und in Verkehr
gebracht werden
überrüstungsexporte entscheidet ein
kabinettsausschuss und zwar im
Einzelfall
Bundessicherheitsrat ist 90% der Arbeit
ist
überrüstungsexporte zu diskutieren die
Angelegenheiten des
bundessicherheitsrats die unterliegen
der Geheimhaltung KritikerInnen sagen
das sei intransparent und der
Bundessicherheitsrat sei nicht
ausreichend demokratisch legitimiert
denn entschieden wird durch
Bundesregierung nicht durch den
Bundestag grundsätzlich wird bei
Rüstungsexporten zwischen EU und
natoländern NATO gleichgestellten
Ländern und sogenannten Drittländern
Unterschieden bei letzteren nimmt sich
die Regierung zurückhaltende Genehmigung
und strenge Kontrollen vor haben sie den
eigenen ethische Richtlinien ja nämlich
wir halten uns an die Spielregeln in
Deutschland und das sind Entscheidungen
unsere Regierung das ist das
Kriegswaffenkontrollgesetz das ist das
Außenwirtschaftsgesetz
Rüstungsexport anbelangt so hat
Deutschland ganz klare Richtlinien und
Grundsätze dabei beruft sich die
Regierung auf sogenannte politische
Grundsätze die die Wahrung der
Menschenrechte in Bestimmungsland
besonders berücksichtigen sollen das
Problem gesetzlich verankert sind diese
Grundsätze nicht der Krieg im Jemen er
verursacht eine der schlimmsten
humanitären Krisen der Welt auch
Waffensysteme mit Komponenten aus
Deutschland sind im Einsatz geliefert an
Saudi-Arabien und die Vereinigten
Arabischen Emirate die am Krieg im Jemen
beteiligt sind es ist das letzte Bild
das Jamaika vor seinem Verschwinden
zeigt eine Überwachungskamera filmt den
saudischen Journalisten am Mittag des 2
Oktober wie er das saudische Konsulat in
Istanbul betritt seitdem fehlt von ihm
jede spurnalist Jamaika wurde ermordet
und das saudische Königshaus soll daran
beteiligt gewesen sein dies war 2018 der
Auslöser für ein weites gehenden Stopp
deutscher Waffenlieferungen nach Saudi
Arabien
Kritik an den Exporten und Beteiligten
Konzernen gab es aber schon vorher
stellen nur diese Waffen her und
verkaufen sich hemmungslos auch eine
Saudi-Arabien auch eine ganze Fabrik die
machen nichts illegales jetzt kann man
sagen die politische Antwort und trägt
natürlich die Bundesregierung die Herz
genehmigt im Koalitionsvertrag von 2018
hieß es wir schränken die
Rüstungsexporte für Drittländer weiter
ein die weder NATO noch
EU-Mitgliedsländer sind wir werden ab
sofort keine Ausfuhren an Länder
genehmigen solange diese unmittelbar am
Jemen Krieg beteiligt sind vielen
KritikerInnen reichte das nicht wir
haben auf dem Papier in der Tat eine
sehr restriktive
rüstungsexportkontrolle auf der anderen
Seite haben wir eben eine Rüstungsexport
Praxis die immer wieder Ausnahmen
zulässt also die auch Rüstungsexporte in
problematische Drittstaaten
zulässt und deswegen brauchen wir eine
gesetzlich verbindliche Regelung die man
dann auch gegenüber der Bundesregierung
einfordern kann die Nachfolge Regierung
aus SPD Grünen und FDP
sich dann 2021 in ihrem
Koalitionsvertrag darauf sich für einen
rüstungsexportkontrollgesetz einzusetzen
Vertreter der Rüstungsindustrie finden
das unverständlich Waffen können töten
aber töten tun ja nicht die Waffen
sondern die Menschen und ein Mensch kann
auch ohne Waffen töten wir sind keine
Waffenschmiede
sondern wir stellen wertechnische
Produkte hier die Soldaten im Einsatz
brauchen die sicherstellen dass sie ihre
Mission erfüllen können von dem
russischen Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine
profitiert die deutsche
Rüstungsindustrie ja weil sich die
Weltlage verändert hat was niemand
wusste werden die jetzt gebraucht und
Schreiben Gewinne aber über viele Jahre
standen die am Rand keiner wollte die
Aktien kaufen viel gravierender als
steigende Aktienkurse könnte aber die
Veränderung in der moralischen Bewertung
der Waffen produzierenden sein in den
80er Jahren beten die Fahnen mit der
Friedenstaube und es hieß Frieden
schaffen ohne Waffen seit Kriegsbeginn
gegen die Ukraine fühlen sich nun die
Rüstungskonzerne gesellschaftlich
deutlich akzeptierter heute findet eine
Mehrheit der Befragten Waffenlieferungen
an die Ukraine angemessen oder will
diese sogar ausweiten wie so ein
Paukenschlag also was vorher schon so
ein bisschen in Schmuddelimage ist
wieder in der gesellschaftlichen
Wahrnehmung finde ich
nach vorne gerückt ob diese veränderte
gesellschaftliche Wahrnehmung am Ende
wirklich zu einer anderen Bewertung von
Waffenherstellung und Waffenexporten
führen wird warten wir es ab Verbände
wie Brot für die Welt kritisieren das
Eckpunktepapier für das geplante
kontrollgesetz das nach dem Angriff auf
die Ukraine verfasst wurde schon jetzt
als halbherzig und zahnlos hat sich euer
Blick auf die Rüstungsindustrie durch
die aktuelle Situation verändert
schreibt es mir in die Kommentare zu
einer weiteren Folge von Kontext geht es
hier und wenn ihr mehr zum Thema wissen
wollt dann klickt doch auf dieses Video